[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y un peu plus de 20 ans ma compagne
et moi on avait un rêve une vieille
maison à la campagne avec des fruitiers
1 puis des oiseaux dans les arbres une
cheminée une belle vue sur la campagne
et puis le rêve est devenu réalité
on agite une vieille ferme en bourgogne
il y avait des fruitiers des oiseaux
dans les arbres un puits une cheminée
une belle vue sur la campagne on a fait
notre potager retourner les pierres est
sous les pierres il y avait des crapauds
en journée ont écouté le chant des
oiseaux et le soir c'était concert des
grillons
et puis
et puis les crapauds ont disparu les
insectes se sont escamotés on n'a plus
entendu les oiseaux fini les mésanges
adieu les chardonnerets
bon journée c'était silence et le soir
c'était aussi silence
cette douloureuse disparition du vivant
autour de moi je ne suis pas le seul à
l'avoir vécu bien évidemment il ya même
des mots pour ça cela stade j et quand
tu y étais mon remède à moi en tant que
journaliste scientifique
ça a été d'écrire un livre
cataclysme une histoire environnementale
de l'humanité
je suis remonté jusqu'aux origines
et j'ai essayé de documenter les
rapports entre l'humanité et son milieu
et rétrospectivement je pense que
c'était une manière de mettre des mots
sur ce que je vivais
de leur côté des scientifiques ont posé
un concept anthropocène l'air de
l'humanité
c'est un mot savant pour dire que nous
vivons désormais sur une planète qui va
se réchauffer
dans un monde où la biodiversité s'érode
dans un monde où le vivant cède
progressivement la place à nos matériaux
inertes
le béton le plastique le goudron et je
pense que c'est le plus angoissant des
saut dans l'inconnu que l'on puisse
concevoir à savoir une terre impacté en
profondeur par nos activités
au point de remettre en question
jusqu'aux fondements mêmes de notre
existence
mais le dire ne suffit pas car nous
sommes en train de le vivre
nous allons devoir vivre en entrepôt
scène et cela implique d'apprivoiser ce
monstre anthropocène si nous voulons lui
survivre et c'est là un programme
politique
alors bien sûr me direz vous le
politique aujourd'hui c'est
l'impuissance
l'impuissance face aux dérèglements
climatiques
l'impuissance face à l'effondrement du
vivant
l'impuissance face à l'extension du
domaine des pollutions
et pourtant il est possible d'aller au
delà mais d'abord pourquoi restons-nous
inerte
d'abord parce qu'il ya
peu de gens qui se saisissent réellement
de l'ampleur du problème
ceux qui essayent de s'investir dans ce
domaine sont trop peu nombreux et ils
font face à deux polarités opposé je
vais prendre l'image d'une rivière
imaginez l'anthropocène comme un flot de
mauvaises nouvelles un torrent
absolument instoppable vous pouvez
essayer de rester au milieu du torrent
de nager dans ce chaos
tout en vous stabilisant en imaginant
que vous pouvez trouver
quelque chose à quoi vous raccrochez un
potager en permaculture un groupe de
paroles mais vous êtes tentés de
rejoindre une dérive et ya deux rives
enfin en tout cas j'en vois deux il y à
la rive des technophiles ceux qui
agitent la main en disant mais la
technologie va nous sauver il y à
l'humanité s'en est toujours sortie elle
s'en sortira encore et puis à la rive
des mystiques ceux qui pensent que la
spiritualité nous permettra de traverser
le pire
pour ma part j'ai plutôt envie de
revenir aux sources du torrent d'opérer
un retour sur l'histoire et d'écouté
d'où pourrait venir cet entrepôt scène
il ya de grandes hypothèses la première
dit l'anthropocène remonte à la
révolution industrielle notamment
l'angleterre où des ingénieurs mettent
au point des perfectionne des moteurs à
combustion basée sur le charbon des
capitalistes investissent ils ramènent
cdc moteur
puissant dans des filatures les ateliers
se transforme en usine les artisans
deviennent des projecteurs tout cela
dégage des profits une petite partie des
profits
russell ra sur les prolétaires qui
formeront une classe moyenne la plus
grande partie des profits ira dans les
poches des élites ce pourquoi certains
veulent parler de capital au scène
puisqu'il a fallu pour que cette
histoire se construisent
qu il y ait des capitaux qui circulent
des capitaux basé sur l'extraction du
charbon mais aussi sur les trafic
d'esclaves sur l'expropriation des
communautés paysannes
mais fondamentalement ce que cela nous
dit de notre monde d'aujourd'hui ce
terme de capital aux scènes c'est que
l'anthropocène est une histoire d'
inégalités parce qu'encore aujourd'hui
les plus riches et met beaucoup plus de
gaz à effet de serre que les plus
pauvres il ya une autre version de cette
histoire on peut la faire remonter à
l'après seconde guerre mondiale
c'est certes le moment où les premières
bombes atomiques laisse une trace sur la
planète sous forme de radiation
perceptible partout sur la planète mais
c'est aussi le moment où s'impose une
révolution verte à travers le plan
marshall les l'argent que les américains
remettent à l'europe
cette révolution verte consiste en fait
à faire main basse sur le vivant de la
part de grandes firmes qui vont produire
des grains
sélectionné hybride donc stérile
modifié par exemple pour avoir plus de
gluten dans le blé
et nécessitant de grands investissements
pour être déployés ainsi qu'une forte
mécanisation
cela implique
des monocultures
les monocultures sont plus fragiles aux
maladies qu'importe on balance dessus la
chimie hérité des deux guerres mondiales
des pesticides
des herbicides
les fongicides
des meurtriers et tout ça détruit la
fertilité du sol en tuant les verts et
les micro organismes qu'importe on a une
solution le procès des abers bosch
développé pour fabriquer des explosifs
on utilise du gaz naturel pour extraire
la zone de l'air et faire des nitrates
tous ces procédés génère énormément de
pollution non seulement du dioxyde de
carbone de l'ammoniaque du méthane et ce
sont donc des pollutions qui affectent
le climat comme le sol l'eau ou les
océans
et c'est pour ça que le vivant recul il
recule d'autant plus vite que ces
procédés la cette histoire là se
reproduit en urbanisme se reproduit
également en industrie les paysans
désertent la campagne les villes
deviennent tentaculaire la voiture se
substituer aux transports en commun et
quant au bétail se retrouvent parquet
est abattu dans des conditions
concentrationnaire on peut alors parler
de thanatos n l'ère de la mort pour
signifier que l'humanité est en guerre
contre le yvan à l'insu de notre plein
gré évidemment
la nature s'effondre donc certes parce
que nous sommes plus nombreux mais ne
nous trompons pas de combat la nature
s'effondre surtout parce que nous la
fractionner
avec nos infrastructures parce que nous
artifices ya dix ans la terre parce que
nous la pollution avec notre chimie et
surtout notre développement
obsessionnellement articulé sur la
croissance de l'idole pib produit
intérieur brut nous pouvons vivre
autrement à 10 milliards sur terre sans
dépasser les limites planétaires avec de
l'agroécologie avec un urbanisme
repenser à l'échelle humaine et de la
solidarité internationale
notre situation résulte de choix
antérieurs qui ont été imposées aux
sociétés je vais prendre l'exemple du
magnat de l'automobile henrie ford qui a
racheté les compagnies de bus et les a
laissé péricliter afin d'imposer sa
solution à lui qu'ils étaient des
voitures construites en ateliers sur des
chaînes de montage
tout en expliquant aux salariés qu'ils
accroissent et leur productivité et donc
leurs salaires alors que c'est dans la
poche d'une reford et dans celle des
actionnaires que terminer les profits
d'autres philanthropes avec les mêmes
arguments ont imposé la révolution verte
par exemple à l'inde aujourd'hui les
paysans indiens se suicident parce
qu'ils n'ont plus les moyens d'acheter
les semences stériles les engrais et les
pesticides qui vont avec alors que leurs
parents nourrissait l'asie avec leur
savoir-faire leur riz leurs méthodes de
désherbage et leurs techniques de
fertilisation à base de collecte des
effluents
si je raconte cela ce n'est pas pour me
lamenter sur le passé car nous vivons
mieux aujourd'hui que nous n'avons
jamais fait de toute l'histoire de
l'humanité je veux dire par là que nous
vivons plus vieux en meilleure santé
avec un accès à beaucoup plus de bien et
d'information que ce que nous pouvions
imaginer il ya même trente ans
mais le co vite 19 nous lance un
avertissement à trop exiger de la nature
à la solliciter au delà du raisonnable
pour soutenir une économie toujours plus
monde en ressources
nous risquons fort d'en payer un prix
extrêmes d'ores et déjà les sécheresses
les méga-feux les inondations les
cyclones
les pollutions de l'air et de l'eau
impact fort s'est fortement des
populations de plus en plus vulnérables
et menace l'équilibré économique mondial
un jour l'économie aux quatre étouffera
et nous nous retrouverons alors dans un
tourbillon de décisions politiques
absurdes
nous avons d'ores et déjà oublié ce qui
fait la valeur d'une vie humaine
l'europe nous parle de démocratie et
criminalise ceux qui tentent de porter
secours aux migrants
notre gouvernement exalte l'écologie et
démantèle pourtant le peu de structures
et de règlement qui permettrait de
protéger la biodiversité
et tout ceci relève du politique je
voudrais citer max weber sociologue qui
au début du 20e siècle écrivait
chacun trouve aujourd'hui en naissant
l'économie capitaliste établi qu'au
maniement ce cosmos
un habitacle dans lequel il doit vivre
et ne peut rien changer
du moins en tant qu'individu
ce que nous disait déjà max weber c'est
que pour faire changer les choses il
faut agir collectivement et donc au
niveau politique cela ne disqualifie pas
ce qui se prépare dans leur vie aux
difficultés ce qui crée des archipels de
résistance car leur expérience sera
utile
pour mobiliser créer des précédents
pousser à l'action mais cela ne suffira
pas à atteindre l'objectif primordial
qui et faire en sorte qu'à l'horizon
2050 quand il lui aura 10 milliards
d'humains sur terre le plus possible de
ces humains puissent vivre une vie digne
et cela dans le respect des limites
planétaires
donc pour vivre un anthropocène
dignement il faut une feuille de route
cela exige de prendre le temps d'étudier
la totalité de l'anthropocène pour mieux
cibler les meilleures façons d'agir
certains veulent tuer la notion
d'entrepôts scène
ils prétendent que ce serait une lubie
de savants fous qui voudraient prendre
le contrôle du système terre avec de la
géo ingénierie
et cette idée serait tellement
dangereuse qu'elle ne mériterait même
pas d'être discutée pourtant
l'anthropocène est un fait
géologiquement constatable l'ensemble de
l'humanité est en train de modifier en
profondeur les paramètres du système
terre
le tout dans un tourbillon d'inégalités
croissantes
et que nous soyons nous humains devenus
la principale force géologique à
l'oeuvre sur terre nous met face à nos
responsabilités
nous perturbons ou détruisons le vivent
comme les ressources en eau la stabilité
climatique comme les seuls qui nous
nourrissent
c'est un fait
et c'est lié à l'économie de croissance
on peut la repeindre en vert ou en bleu
cela n'y changera rien il nous faut
changer radicalement de comportement
et il faut prendre l'anthropocène pour
ce qu'est ce qu'il est à savoir une
enveloppe une enveloppe dans laquelle
l'humanité peut mettre en commun ses
attentes ses espoirs ses craintes et ses
récits
et c'est une enveloppe dans laquelle
nous allons puiser nos connaissances
pour nous battre on peut prendre par
exemple dans cette enveloppe la carte
agriculture du futur ça peut être une
agriculture à base d'agroécologie
où l'on sortira progressivement des
intrants chimiques
et où on sortira également le bétail des
conditions concentrationnaire dans
laquelle il se trouve il y a une autre
carte agriculture du futur dedans c'est
celle de l'économie comme elle existe
aujourd'hui
est celle ci sera à base d'eau gm
ce sera une agriculture sans paysans où
les robots le travail des paysans ou des
abeilles et où les pesticides seront
toujours plus volumineux et toujours
plus toxiques
aujourd'hui en occident nous vivons dans
un confort que personne avant nous dans
l'histoire n'a jamais connu et c'est
pour ça que nous restons inerte
personne n'a envie de renoncer à ce
confort pour entrer en lutte
ce que nous dit l'anthropocène c'est que
pourtant nous devons renoncer à certains
des éléments qui font ce confort
il faudra à l'avenir manger moins de
viande
travailler moins faire preuve de plus de
solidarité
s'efforcer de brider les firmes dans
leur accès aux ressources afin de mieux
les répartir
il faudra se mesurer à l'entrepôt scène
pour faire en sorte qu'à l'horizon 2050
le plus possible de gens puissent vivre
dignement
seule une mobilisation citoyenne nous
permettra d'obliger les états à prendre
en compte non pas leur seul intérêt
égoïste mais les intérêts de l'ensemble
de l'humanité
et ce n'est pas un choix
c'est une nécessité
morale
du vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]